Okay, this might sound a bit strange but
imagine you're building a user interface
for screen reading users only.
So you don't need to create
any visual UI at all.
Just provide enough information for
the screen reader to use.
How would you express the form interface
we used in the previous exercise?
Well, what you'd be creating is kind of
an API describing the page structure.
That sounds kind of like the dom API.
But we can get away with less
information and fewer nodes.
Because a lot of that information is
useful only for visual presentation.
Sorry, something like this.
This enables a screen reader user to
jump in between high level sections and
then get enough information about
each form element's affordances
to know how to fill them in.
Remember, for a screen reader user, the
screen reader provides the affordances
based on the role alone without
caring about the visual style.
This is more or
less what the browser actually
does present to the screen reader.
What happens is that the browser
takes the DOM tree and
modifies it to turn it into a form which
is useful to assistive technology.
We refer to this modified tree
as the accessibility tree.
In my mind, the accessibility tree
conceptually looks a bit like
an HTML page from the 90s.
You may have seen web
pages that look like this.
You can picture the mark up, I'm sure.
A few carefully chosen images,
a lot of links, a text box and a button.
Visually scanning down the page in this
case gives you an experience pretty
similar to what a screen
reader user would get.